testing okay there we go hello
it's not coming through this hello hello
what's up
go here can we hear me now
it's like the Sprint guy or the T-Mobile
guy whatever it was
should be good now right
yes no yes I'm seeing pink okay cool
cool cool cool cool
I don't know I start coming through my
headset
test test
well it's fine I'll use the microphone
that I have right here
it's not even in the shot either
I'm not sure Daredevil's popping up
tonight y'all I really don't know I'm
I'm really in uh
I'm really not uh low audio let's turn
it
up a little bit how about oh now it
seems to be peaking
how about now better
let me pull it up on YouTube
[Music]
I'm not seeing it oh no
is it better now guys
testing testing testing testing
oh it says people say perfect now
Jeff likes K-pop what is up
my hair is it really that noticeable
huh
I didn't think it was that noticeable
all right cool though we we got this
we're live
we're chilling and all right
I don't I don't know
I don't know if Daredevil's popping up
today I really don't I
I want to say you showing up an episode
I mean I don't want to say it
um I just
that's what I think that's what I'm
thinking is gonna happen
audio overlap Sue I think it's just
because I was just checking it out on my
phone real quick
uh no problem Felipe no problem no
problem
yeah I think it was my my phone fall
guy's grind Jeff noise dude I play fall
guys too
I won like three times the other day
with my friends
how many episodes are there total
nine there was supposed to be ten
and then they cut it down to nine
it's unfortunate for us
Christopher sells our greetings from
Mexico hola I'm actually part Mexican
my mom's Mexican my grandma's from
Mexico
Daredevil here today
is it it's really what's really funny is
I guess like on the stream is it looks
like really orange and bright but it's
just because I have these really bright
lights like hitting me right right on
the face
it's really just like lightish brown
the shadow catcher thank you for that
super chat I really appreciate it
so far the show has been a comedy do you
think it will end on something serious
for the future of the show and the MCU
you know I do think there is like
something more serious going on in the
background I think it's Gonna Keep the
light-heartedness the funniness of it
but just add the like seriousness to it
so I don't think it's necessarily going
to lose the comedy aspect to it and I
don't think it'll I don't think it'll
end
on something like super super serious
but I do think it will set something up
but I think they will keep that
comedy aspect to it I do think that
oh I know I'm uh
I was pretty disappointed in d23 I'm not
gonna lie like I was pretty disappointed
Uh Kevin feige was like
he said it was going to be
I'm not sure if he said it was going to
be really big or if he said it was going
to be bigger than sdcc I I saw some
people say like oh Kevin foggy said was
going to be bigger
but I I don't know what his actual quote
was but he did say it was going to be
big I expected phase six I really I
really did and uh
all the Insiders were saying a lot of
different stuff and none of it came true
it almost makes me wonder like did
Marvel hear all of it
did Marvel hear all of it and
did they change things you know you
never know you know you never know
Bucky Barnes they tell hey what's up Joe
thanks for Super Chat how's it going
how's it going
uh can we get a wild Cameo prediction
for She-Hulk
a wild Cameo prediction somewhere in the
realm of reality let me hmm
in the realm of reality I mean
Spiderman so here's the thing
the crew and like the writers the
writing room for She-Hulk
said that they were disappointed because
Spider-Man was one of those names that
was off the table however while that
probably is true because of the whole
Sony deal however
that could be saying that just to really
surprise us by having a Spider-Man cameo
that would be my wild one that like has
a chance of being true
but probably won't happen you asked for
a while that's that's what I think wow
yeah I'm
I
I think I I've said this before in a
video I oops I don't even remember which
video it was I think it was like a week
we can have a go excuse me
I don't think you can just have one to
come back randomly before Secret Wars
because she did a lot of bad stuff I
love Wanda and I'm fine
but if you think about it from like
Wong's perspective from like Doctor
Strange's perspective like she killed
Sorcerers like she was at the cometage
and killed Sorcerers you know
so it's like can she just come back and
be
a good guy I think yes but I don't think
it's without like Wong and Doctor
Strange going like whoa hold the heck up
last time we dealt with you you almost
you know you were wreaking havoc who
crossed the Multiverse you killed the
freaking
I almost said Sinister Six You Killed
the Illuminati
um I'm sure in some university did Kill
The Sinister Six but she killed the
Illuminati and all the stuff and I just
think like you have to have another
movie or show or something she has to
come back before Secret Wars
in order for her to like be good like be
a part of the good guys team and maybe
she doesn't have to be maybe she just
shows up as a variant and just kind of
like
what is happening and they're like Wanda
we know what happened before but we need
you to help like that could happen I
think it would
it wouldn't do it justice like I think
she needs to come back before
and it really makes you
it really makes you wonder what they
have like in store for phase six because
like why didn't they reveal it
like are they they're real I I just feel
that they're really
they're really going to make us wait
till sdcc 2023 to to reveal phase six
and I'm like holy crap
so rocket is here
today but here's the deal rocket just
recently had surgery
I don't know if you can see but she's
got a cone on her head
she's got a cone on her head so she's
not feeling
too great right now what she's doing
she's doing good she's got a big old
scar on her on her butt
on her back
from where the surgery was
she's doing all right
and Chantix what's up how's it going
to see you here
Chas D Bianco you know what
you're not wrong
Cameo is uh
you know
you're right um
especially I'm trying to remember I
think it was last episode right
or it could have been she woke up said
three where she was like you know I
don't want to expect a cameo each week
you don't even know we got a meal
Abomination Wong
you know
yeah
yeah thank you all for the for the
wishes for Rocket she's doing much
better my other cat has some
little health issues as well but uh
Rocket's doing much better aren't you
want to say hi to everybody
want to show him your scar
you could pull a joker and say you know
how I got these scars
here's rocket in the cone
I don't think I could show her scar
without
putting her in
I don't even know what side it's on what
you doing
oh it's on this side I can't show it
she's not having a good time
oh I got it oh
no
he's okay
there we go we go
and she's like what the heck dad
okay sorry
oh
there we go
Sean what's up man
everybody stuck around my hair thank you
I don't
is it really that big of a difference
I'm looking at my the phone like
the lights make it look a lot lighter
than it actually is
but anyways uh
Sean where was your there you go
who would I choose
to direct King Dynasty and Secret Wars
well Dustin Daniel [ __ ] is directing
uh King Dynasty
I would
I'm light hesitant to to see this but I
would like the rooster Brothers to come
back to direct Secret Wars that's what
they talked about before they said they
would come back for it
and I think they would do a pretty good
job
there's only a few things I would change
about endgame
but besides that
they did a really great job Infinity War
I mean I I personally enjoyed Infinity
War a little a little bit better than in
game it's hard to say that you know
because they are two very different
movies but an Infinity War was
really really great
really really great
do we do I think Henry 47 key do I think
we'll see Bruce Banner again
I don't really know I don't think so
maybe you what you said maybe maybe a
post-credit scene
besides that I don't I don't
yeah
yeah
I did
uh get to interview two of the main cast
members of the Andor Star Wars show
today
um Kyle and audreya and Adria was the
main uh actress in morbius and I wanted
to ask her about morbius like so badly
but I also wanted to be professional and
respectful like I was doing the Star
Wars and or interview why I wasn't doing
a you know I wasn't doing a morbius
interview so I didn't ask her about that
because
I wanted to be professional and
respectful but I really wanted to be
like it's morbid time
yeah
so
thank you wtbs I appreciate that yeah we
are four minutes away uh
I need to get ready uh zuhad the Sharif
what I think the future of Marvel is I
think the future Marvel is the X-Men and
the Fantastic Four I think that's
um phase seven I think that's that's
what it's gonna be
I'm gonna pull up oh you know what I
need to do
I need to do this
I need to fix one thing and then we need
to pull up Disney Plus
and
fixed
and Disney Plus
also Mr Anderson glad you're here glad
it all worked out I think I just saw a
message from you I didn't actually I
like saw it in my notifications
but I didn't actually see the message
yet also for the K-pop fans
I got black pink tickets and I got the
super VIP
uh
experience I think is what it's called
so I'm really excited about that is it
out oh no
three minutes
three minutes
wait guys I just exited because I'm
stupid
foreign
boom
Sue which is correct midnight Sons or
suns suns with an O
not a u
but I can understand how
yeah
yeah yeah release the more been cut
I did not watch brahmuster yet but it
does look amazing and Disney actually
did give me the opportunity to Herb
because Disney owns 20th century now so
20th century gave me the opportunity to
see it beforehand unfortunately I was
not in town at the time uh to see it but
it looks really good
do you think Fantastic Four and X-Men
stuff will take place in our current
unit Multiverse or a new one I think it
should take place in our current one and
if you take a look at Miss Marvel they
clearly have established her as a mutant
They even played the X-Men 97 theme song
you know I think that's happening in our
universe
are they gonna explore other universes
maybe I think it gets complicated but
I'm for it I know people like us we we
really look into this stuff and we love
this stuff
I would love it and I think other people
would love it but I think the problem is
the general population who goes to watch
these movies who aren't super fans like
us are gonna get really confused
unfortunately and that is something the
studios take into account
would you rather watch more videos so
listen to K-pop for 20 foot K-pop that's
pretty easy what's up Sam Wilson it's
dick thank you for that super chat I
really appreciate it would like to say I
really like your videos big fan thank
you so much also when do you think the
casting info for a Fantastic Four will
come out I I talked about this a little
bit in the beginning of the stream I'm
really hoping Marvel Studios isn't
waiting for sdcc 2023
next year I'm really hoping that's not
the case we do have Disney investors day
coming up and
you know
maybe something in between will happen
but right now I'm thinking we have to
wait a year till the next sdcc
unfortunately
yeah Billy Buck news can we expect a
review
um maybe I'm kind of trying to do I
might be trying to do reviews on my my
second Channel Cosmic entertainment
um I'm trying to structure that in a way
to where it's like
strictly kind of like news on this
channel and like theories and then like
interviews and stuff on the other I'm
still gonna post interviews on this one
but
um maybe I I I would like to do a review
on it I don't know if it'll be posted
Cosmic Wonder we'll see it's out okay oh
Mr Anderson I need to get
um
every every week I question what it is
stopwatch stopwatch
we're gonna pop this into a new window
all right I haven't seen this one so I'm
excited Let me refresh it right here
it's loading
mean green and straight poured 31
minutes going straight poured into these
jeans all right let's do it we're going
to start in five four
three two one
uh let me just make sure it's sync there
we go
oh I can't hear anything
couldn't I hear anything
my headset like isn't
maybe if I plug it in
the heck
I can't hear
uh speakers it is hopefully it doesn't
is that picking up like a lot in the
microphone
I'll turn it down
is that picking up a lot into the
microphone
definitely in Korean still
can you guys hear that
definitely in Korean still I'll turn
down my mic
all right
foreign
I kind of just did that
the people love the She-Hulk
why would you let her do that
little child oh my gosh
she does know who she is
anything
thank you
oh my gosh she like covers that she she
covers the girl she's with
my headphones are not working so I'm
using speakers so I'll just mute my mic
when I'm not talking
because it's smart that's why she's rich
in your book oh I love this guy
done
the Iron Man threes are coming out
one to rock him on the stock I love that
I respect that
my drip broker
Alonzo the drip broker
oh there we go she's gonna get her suit
now
I really like bug
because you're right you're right
titaniacs look at that
are we about to see some cameos here a
superhero clothing business
the trip broker he sent me
you're right Sue I do get Kingsman vibes
I feel so much shame
he freaking scared me
yo yo
Avengers
with an i
he's got a hammer and a shield
he's he's got the shield and the hammer
on
they got all the merch now
look at him dance oh my gosh
I like [ __ ] a lot he's he's a good
character
Nikki is really great too
all right we about to see some new
clients what's happening
She-Hulk booty boo smoothie
it's not
it's not her fault
that she was going to
we're not call oh geez she's intense
did Thor
people use their real names it's the
clip we saw today
what's up taruka
legally outmaneuvered you
no they both are you too
nice suit Shrek
oh she's a good lawyer
sham products
I really like Titania
well I really like Jamila
you you can sit down
oof that's that's facts
I am forever Shield there it is
yo titanium freaking
I'm pretty sure she can't do that in
court
appointment who is the dresser we have
to figure out who this dresser is this
is gonna be something
this will be funny
maybe not let's see who is it
oh
that convention oh geez
she's an adventure there you go the Hulk
is her cousin
I really like Nikki she's really cool
okay there's gotta be Easter eggs for
like other people he makes suits for
right there has to be something in there
what I'm I'm getting John Wick Vibes now
like you know bulletproof suits and
stuff like that
please get out
oh she's gonna transform back to her
normal self and there it is
and fish
spandex you need spandex
stretch wool oh what is this
was that Z
eus's thing no
no Subway with belly oh no this guy
I feel like you did know
oh he sucks he sucks he sucks
I hate him
so he's like the bag
the bad guy right
he is the Baywatch guys lost a lot of
weight but he's got to be the bad guy
he did go on a date with She-Hulk
oh that is a clear pattern of the name
look at that
no she has to get all the men
oh my gosh I love how extra Titania is
she sits and throws it off
as you can see in the about oh boy
I start you back and reinforce
king-sized bed
can she film that I'm not sure she can
Jamila is oh gosh look at all these guys
oh no
oh this was the guy who was
the red the writer yeah
well they're all pissed
oh I hate them all
and then here's this douchebag
she did battle demons
nope because he bailed
foreign
I mean geez what a
what a kick to The Shins
look at that
they will cease usage wow
all products must be recalled oh she's
really called her a hater
I think Daredevil will appear in the
next one
fine you can buy me things
don't do it Jen slash She-Hulk don't go
back to any of those stupid guys
this is really weird camera work here I
don't like it
with that extremely attractive man said
there
in the comics her character is a bad guy
so I'm kind of concerned for Jen at this
point
the medium bucks
oh they're not friends oh
I thought you were getting better
clothes I feel I don't know how I feel
about this girl because again she is a
in a comic she is a bad guy
uh watching on our own fire kit because
unfortunately Disney blocks it now and I
can't show it on my screen so
there's really no way around that
unfortunately
I like this guy
of course you do because I'm a genius
what's the extra show me the extra
yeah this guy had to have made Daredevil
stuff right
Daredevil man oh this is the Daredevil
helmet Daredevil helmet look at that
oh that was the end that was the end
let's see what the push credit is
wait is there no post credit
there's no post credit
no post credit huh okay okay
I I'm not happy I was right
but I I did call it there's a tease for
Daredevil at the end of this but he's
gonna actually be in the next episode
I'm not happy about it but I I kind of
am I'm not happy because I I would have
rather have seen him you know
in this episode
let me fix this get rid of the timer
well oh I'm tired
what did we think
of this episode
what we think
yeah I don't think there is a
post-credit scene I just looked I
skimmed over it a few times I'll do it
one more time just to make sure but
that's really weird I guess just because
the I guess just because
of the Daredevil tees
it's very clearly
yellow too let's take a look
I'm so tired
it's very yellow
very yellow
I don't even think like
it's not it won't even show it on the
screen
look at that
like it just shows
it just shows
like I'll show you
see it doesn't show a picture on my
screen I can see the picture right here
like this is Daredevil's helmet right
here but I don't know how Disney figured
out how to block that I don't that's
some technological craziness to me
I want to see them fight but not
but not at the court in a very peaceful
way we get to see them fight
pretty soon I mean in the what do they
call it mid
-season trailer Peak or something like
that they showed I think it was Titania
punching Jen in the face or She-Hulk in
the face
okay overall
this show seems to be ranking a little
bit lower than the other episodes I
think the last episode was my favorite
so far maybe the first
show up but his helmet did so he was
there
C minus
yeah it was Daredevil it was the helmet
it was a
it was the big little DD
yeah let's uh I want to see something
here
I want to see if I can see any other
suits
there's a suit
behind him behind the Daredevil helmet
and I just I can't make it out
I'm trying to see other suits
here's a corset for somebody like
it's got flowers on it who Could That Be
for
also how did Titania get her powers like
I have I have a lot of questions
that right there just looks like
like a vest I
what is that
I want to know what this something extra
is too he said I made her a little
something extra I'm curious as to what
that is
all right
I can't make out
I can't make out what these other
clothes are
I mean could that be a dorm a lot no
they want to do that they would have
vibranium suits
something infused with vibranium
it's hard to make out when I freeze this
Frame
tell I just can't tell
but the Daredevil helmet is uh freaking
yeah
it's freaking yeah that's
look at that
so cool so cool I can't wait for
Daredevil to show up
Charlie Cox Matt Murdock
love it love it love it
the shoes during the credit Abe the
thing Dr Doom and even Deadpool sneakers
let's take a look at that Deadpool
sneakers
I didn't really look at the credits in
all honesty
the Deadpool sneakers the thing let's
take a look
Von Jers that that part was funny
that's whose suit
did anybody catch anything
about
in that scene
sorry I'm trying to focus anybody catch
any superhero suits that they recognized
in that final scene there
signed by She-Hulk She-Hulk by Titania
well that sucks for her
She-Hulk booty boost
and the guys are drinking it
the iron okay okay okay
oh I see Cyclops shoes
Captain Marvel
is are those Green Goblin shoes
and then that's Vision those are Vision
shoes the thing
where's people said Deadpool
I'm not seeing Deadpool
oh oh more are being revealed in the
back
is that that's an anova that's a black
panther
that's a Thor because of the Wings
I don't know how that is
it's hard to make that out
wait okay
oh okay now I see it Deadpool okay
there's a lot okay Captain America
the thing Vision Cyclops Spider-Man
black panther Moon Knight
what's the green shoe with the lightning
bolt and the yellow
uh I wish I could show you the photo of
the shoes but it literally blocks it
from me showing it to you
I don't know how to I don't know how to
show it
I see Deadpool in the right now I wasn't
in the right frame before
who's the purple who
maybe Electro yeah maybe that makes
sense
looks like maybe a Star-Lord one
or or or Nova one I see the Hulk
Dr Doom is top left
where I'm missing that one
uh the time step is 25 31.
yeah I could use my phone
I see ah crap
yeah the thing what I clearly see
you said but somebody said Doom was
was top left
Venom in the back
where's Venom
time stamp 25 31 I'm also working on
getting it on my phone
wait
what it but I'm confused y'all people
say Venom I'm not singing Venom I see a
black panther shoe
I mean it's gonna be extremely hard to
make out
oh come on Disney plus this app is not
the best
it's really not the no freaking a and it
just moved
so there's this scene let me pull up my
camera
so he showed they showed like a bunch of
different shoes right
so the these are clearly Iron Man threes
this is a Captain Marvel
and then right here is Cyclops
this is a cyclops shoe right here this
is vision and this is the thing right
here
and then
there's a pumpkin on this one and it's
like screen scale so I think it's the
Green Goblin
Dr Doom above Captain Marvel no if
there's a pumpkin on it so I think
that's
that's the Green Goblin
Colossus above Spider-Man
I think
uh Captain Marvel is above Spider-Man
third down second half is Colossus
but doesn't it have an M on it you're
talking about to the left of the thing
shoe
so we're looking at all the different
shoes that there are
black and yellow could be Iron Fist
maybe here
for those wondering what we're looking
at we're looking at all these different
shoes there's Deadpool right there
that red one it very clearly stills out
stands out
um well so far everything that has been
drawn has actually showed up in one way
or another
I'm not gonna lie like what is this
oh is that an is that Falcon that's the
original colors for falcon
there's a like okay on the left side
second row the red and white shoes next
to the Hulk shoes is that falcon
I think Nova is the one with the three
not the three yellow things yeah
I I think I don't know I'm thinking that
these might these might be Cannon
I really do
what about okay on the right side the
first one on the very top it's like
purple and pink it looks like it has an
H on it
I'm confused at what it is
oh you know what I think that is a
Silver Surfer under Deadpool
I'm having trouble making some of these
out I really am
uh okay turn Network acceleration off in
your browser
let's try that
I don't know how to do that but we're
gonna try that
settings
somebody tell me how to do that tell me
how to turn the network acceleration off
I mean maybe Big T
uh
uh I don't know how to do that
I don't know how to turn that off
turn off Network acceleration
how to turn off Network X
acceleration is that we're using
sure
let's figure that out
no I'm using internet whatever it's
called
uh which ones are the Ghost Rider ones
Edward
click the display adapter properties for
display one what
what
that's a lot that's a lot of stuff
okay I can't do that right now that's a
that's a lot of
a lot of different settings okay
people keep talking about
the Luke Cage poster on the wall what is
the time stamp for that
25
28 for the Luke Cage poster
no 25 28 we're still on the
I can't take a screenshot I I've tried
it doesn't even let you take a
screenshot from your phone
can somebody tell me when the loot where
the loot cage poster is so I know where
to look
that's a shield file
2546 I see The Shield logo
I'm still looking for the
check your Twitter attack doing a full
oh thanks Jen
I could bring that up
Twitter
oh sign in yes
get rid of these get rid of these get
rid of these full picture
cool okay here we go
full picture of the shoes
boom
okay
so what do we have here
thank you Jen for that
so all right
this right here
I think is Nova
well who are these just yellow ones
who is just yellow
any idea who's just yellow
these are ghost riders looks like
Ghost Riders right here
I I are these falcon
I think these are falcon
is that what we think we think this is
Wolverine the yellow
or the new Daredevil Maybe
these are the hulks I think these are
falcon I can't really make out this top
one
um
what are frog man because he's coming I
see like two big eyes here
yeah uh this looks like an H but it's
like it's pink and purple it's like
Magneto colors to me
um
these are the thing this is vision
Cyclops Black Panther
Spider-Man Captain Marvel this is
probably Electro
um
these are Moon Knight I can't this is
just like a green thing I don't know
what that is Deadpool is up here
oh this is a Star-Lord one we can see
right here
um these might be the Silver Surfers
they're not filled in yet
of course Captain America what is this
this looks
oh I know this I can't I can't put my
finger on it what is this who are these
who are these who are these
oh Hawkeye duh oh my gosh thank you
revolin thank you I'm stupid
one above a Hulk is Colossus these
okay so Iron Fist yellow shoes Maybe
who are these oh they have wings on them
so that's going to be Thor
with the little tiny wings right here so
that's Thor right
next to cap is probably storm you think
these are storms
one above Hulk is gamut you think these
are Gambit
uh name or
uh
I don't
wait which one are y'all saying his name
more
wait everyone's saying name or who who
which one
oh this one oh that makes sense okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
wait below Cyclops is Arthur Haro I I
think this is Black Panther below
cyclops
wait with the wings
the winged ones the Epic Spire what do
you say what about the winged ones who
are
what are what are we saying I know he
has wings on his feet
oh
are those I guess yeah Green yeah I
guess yeah
who are the who are the top left like
what what is this
what are these brown ones
like what are these
Hawkeye all right we can't see those
whose logo is this
okay so that's Neymar the wings and
Neymar
who the heck okay so what are these pink
or pink what are these yellow and blue
ones
and what are these
huh
have we figured out have we figured out
all but
but the brown ones
no I don't think that's a four in the
circle
no I don't I don't think it's a circle I
think it's like an X
or like a you know like a plus sign or
something
brown ones could be for Groot yeah
yellow and blue could be Wolverine
yeah Ghost Rider is right here
oh Juggernaut you think that's a
juggernaut
this is Colossus
where are the Galactus shoes I'm not
seeing the galactic shoes
Deadpool very clearly there
it's wonderful Moon Knight that to me
that that looks like just Spider-Man
yeah these are the Green Goblins
Electro
uh
I think that's Doctor Strange yeah I
guess that yeah
seriously this photo is like the most
captivating thing so far
you think this is Doom
uh I think I know we I think frog man is
coming in this I think this is frog man
okay so cable everyone's thinking this
is cable
and people think this is Doom
uh angel on the top right I'm not seeing
angel
thank you Corey King for that
for that uh top right though
um you're talking about angel the X-Men
whose real name is Warren like my name
I think yellow white is storm
like like these
so people are saying these are Jubilee
shoes
and then next to cap is shocker there's
so many
we're getting so many different reports
here
I can see how it could be shocker
uh
uh I could I I could see how it could be
Jubilee
dang
yeah I can see how it could be either or
Bucktown Bounty thanks for super check
green yellow and white pair uh are you
talking about
green green
this one
green yellow and white
green yellow there's only green yellow
and white one I see right here
I think these are fragment look at these
two eyes they look like big frog eyes
and we know frogman's actually coming in
in She-Hulk
yeah I think we were talking about this
being Luke cages that makes sense
Brown and orange we think is Daredevil
whose are these
this be America Chavez no I don't I
don't think so
yeah the Cyclops shoes are sweet
oh you know what this could be America
Chavez this could that would make sense
because she's you know in the MCU right
now
yeah we think this is Dr Doom not
frogman
a lot of different a lot of different a
lot of different inputs here
these
yeah Miss Marvel okay now I see what
you're saying the M for Miss Marvel okay
well that's cool
skipped Tosh
yeah that makes sense that those would
be
Miss Marvel blue red yellow or Bishop
these
uh
you think this is Dr Doom under black
panther
and now people are saying this isn't
even oh man
this is going to tear the fandom apart
this is gonna tear the Phantom apart
whose are these though just kidding I
obviously know they're the Iron Mans
so the only ones that really got me
this probably Doctor Stranger these
brown ones up here
these brown ones up here
this one right here could be Jubilee
or who else did we think it could have
been
Jubilee is shocker
um
and then these I do think are frog man
these would be Hawkeye so I think I'm
just stuck on these yellow and blue ones
here and these right here
so one two three I don't know the brown
and the orange could be rocket
uh
I don't know whose these are I I really
don't
I can I can like all of these the M this
one's kind of confusing me and then this
one and this one I don't know who these
are
oh man
I think this is cable
I don't think that's cable
I'm maybe
oh man
yellow blue Wolverine okay I can see
that
yellow white with X-Men sign a storm I
don't know if that's
I don't know if that's the X-Men sign
though
I mean it could be
uh that's a tough one
oh
I'm really struggling here I mean
I want to say yes
especially with like the in the in her
like whitish yellow suit she has the
uh like the X's to like hold her Cape
right
yeah that yeah you know what that yeah
yeah I'm I I think I think storm
yeah I'm there
we have the thing she was right here
and the thing was rumored to be coming
in an episode so I'm like holy crap what
is going on here
hmm
I think this is Bishop
foreign
yeah
that is Bishop
you're right
so Bishop
Namor right
Hawkeye up here
Bishop
frog man I think
the brown ones could be Wong's yeah I
mean
I think this is Professor X
yeah maybe
uh
uh yeah these seem to be America Chavez
not Captain America
so America Chavez Deadpool storm this
could be Professor X Hawkeye
probably frog man Bishop the thing
vision
uh Norman Osborne Green Goblin Cyclops
Captain Marvel Spider-Man black panther
Moon Knight Electro
Namor Luke Hulk
Falcon Nova
Ghost Rider Doctor Strange probably Wong
since it's next to Doctor Strange these
look like they could possibly be the
Silver Surfer and these are star-lords
huh
that's a good point Mohit Professor X
can't walk when he gets shoes
I don't know what this is I can't tell
what this is either that's a tough one
to
I think no I I definitely think the m is
Bishop thank you two pointed that out
wait I thought we thought that the
the blue and the yellow could be
Wolverine
the blue and yellow over yeah I I would
say Wolverine the blue and the yellow I
want to say Wolverine uh
that's true Olek he does still need
shoes I mean
so
these right here you think or right here
these are
invisible women's shoes yeah
you think the Wing boots are Rogues I
thought we thought that was Namor
I didn't miss Moon Knight I see
Moonlight right here
all right so
I don't know I I think I think the blue
and the yellow make more sense
but you're right the brown and the
orange could be
why do we think the Wing boots are are
rogue though
some people think this is Dr Doom I see
that
I think the blue and yellow Wolverine
okay so here's where we're at
here's where we at
America Chavez Deadpool probably the
Silver Surfer
Star-Lord
storm
Wolverine the thing Vision Cyclops black
panther possibly Doom Moon Knight
Spider-Man Captain Marvel
Green Goblin
Bishop
probably frog man maybe Doom
Hawkeye I can't make that out
Hulk
Luke Cage Namor
Electro
Nova
falcon
Doctor Strange
Ghost Rider Sue storm Invisible Woman
uh
what did we think about the brown and
orange one possibly Wong's because the
next Doctor Strange
um yeah I can get on board with that
possibly being the Scarlet Spider does
kind of look like that symbol but it
also
uh
man I don't know
I think the Wing boots are named War
because of the Wings themselves
I don't think they're Rogue
uh I don't know Mr Anderson talk
tomorrow
can't what
be Gambit Sue
the one below
could the one below one be Ant-Man yeah
maybe
uh
so we're thinking that this one might be
Professor X or Wolverine
oh oh you might be right there there
might be a spade on that uh waviest
Chief you're right that might be Gambit
uh
interesting that could be a spade
not really his colors though
the one of the
top left could begin but maybe
oh
like up here yeah I mean I don't I can't
tell if that is a spade
oh
that's uh yeah that's that's a little
that's a little difficult
huh
that's hard
right that's what I'm thinking I was
like Gambit has the purple I'm
so that's why I'm not so sure like yes
it looks like it has a spade on it but
like
uh
not really his colors
um
Mr Fantastic under pugs elbow I don't
know
I don't know how to advance frames per
seconds on this
hmm
[Music]
well I think we got most of them
I kind of just went with Falcon on this
we think it's uh
falcon
oh man
oh
[Music]
do play and pause on Disney plus really
fast and you will advance a few frames
um
problem is if I do that
you won't be able to see it but let me
try it
oh yeah I can see it's clearly a spade
there
it is a spade
I think those are
frog man
that does really look like a spade I
know you can't see it
but it does look like a spade
that's uh
interesting
oh no
hmm
dang well
well this is something
this is fun
man
foreign
wow
I think this is Hawkeye because it has
the h
mm
man there's a lot
there's a lot in just this
uh the problem is is
I don't really get I don't get
notifications
from
people that I don't follow that's the
problem
so I can't actually what's your Twitter
tag then I can look that up
the ones you hold in are most likely
Iron Man yes I believe these are Iron
Man
interesting
this is the post-credits scene I fully
believe that this is the post-credits
scene
ah
dang
these look like they could be wings too
those could be Thor
so here's what's interesting is a lot of
this stuff
a lot of this stuff
a lot of these like paintings or
sketches or whatever
um
they've typically happened
um you know
they've typically happened they've
we've seen a lot of the the sketches
come to play in the actual show so I'm
thinking this is an actual scene
where pug does go to get the the Iron
Man threes and we see all these other
shoes
so yeah
I think
I think this is some sort of a
confirmation here I really do
which is crazy
like actually crazy
wow okay well
I clearly have a lot of work to do
oh
yeah I see the color I got the color in
the shoes next to Hawkeye
um they do look like Spade it does look
like a spade
dang
yes Hunter
x76 we do uh we do know
I know right we need these shoes I feel
like we actually do need these shoes
Okay
um
Iceman is bottom left next to his elbow
right here no you can't see it anymore
but
I think that's Iceman it could be
well
yeah these are current uh
hmm
no no Justine pug did not pug is
covering a lot so is Nikki
but Deadpool
and does this mean well Vision was
already in I guess phase four so
yeah this isn't actually from Disney
plus guys this is just a tweet because
Disney plus is it blocks I won't show it
on stream
okay well
hmm
I have to get to bed because I have to
work clearly I have to work so
ah man the top left corner I want to say
is Wong
because it's next to Doctor Strange oh
man that's really hard that's really
hard
I do need the Deadpools though I would
wear the Deadpools
the cyclopses are freaking
those are pretty dope
that was a pretty dope
whose helmet is that that is Daredevil's
helmet yes yes yes yes
I think yellow shoes we went for Luke
Cage
so but all right y'all I I gotta I gotta
stop I'm very tired
um
Lots
lots to do tomorrow
so I'm gonna wake up early
and work on this
because there is a lot here
so
all right
that's a lot it's a lot to look at but
okay well thanks everybody for stopping
by the stream really appreciate it I uh
it wasn't my favorite She-Hulk episode
but this is awesome
this is honestly the best part of the
episode uh this is
this is pretty cool this is like the
best part so all right
um I love you all I'm so grateful for
the support of you all and thankful to
everybody who stopped by whether you
super chat I just chatted just watched
thank you for coming we will uh be doing
same watch party next week and I'll be
breaking this down
today slash tomorrow today really uh I'm
just gonna get a few hours of sleep wake
up and and do it if I didn't have such a
blinding headache right now from a lack
of sleep I would definitely just do this
right now but
I'm gonna get some sleep first you can
check out Mr Anderson's Channel he has
one of his own he put the link down
there below and if you're not subbed to
me feel free to
um especially if you want to get
notified about this uh breakdown right
here tomorrow so I'm gonna do a video
just on this it it's it deserves its own
video
uh
uh yeah Louis me too I hope I the Lord
of the Rings has been slow but I'm
excited so daredeva next week and uh
look out for the breakdown tomorrow all
right